يواصل القاده وزعماء العرب التوافد على
مدينه جده السعوديه للمشاركه في قمه جامعه
الدول العربيه الثانيه والثلاثين التي
تعقد اليوم الجمعه فقد وصل عدد من رؤساء
الدول العربيه من بينهم الرئيس السوري
بشار الاسد والرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد
والرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي والرئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس كما وصل ايضا رئيس
حكومه تصريف الاعمال اللبنانيه نجيب
ميقاتي وملك البحرين حمد بن عيسى الخليفه
والرئيس الموريتاني محمد ولد الشيخ احمد
الغزواني اضافه
لنائب رئيس الوزراء اسعد بن طارق رئيس وفد
سلطنه عمان وتبحث القمه قضايا رئيسيه عده
منها القضيه الفلسطينيه والازمه السودانيه
بالاضافه الى ملفات اقتصاديه في اطار
الخطط التنمويه للجامعه العربيه